so this is a mainly a performance talk
and I hope everyone's interested in
performance here so I'm going to talk
about some of the pitfalls you run into
when you try to paralyze the random
forest algorithm and I'll give an
introduction to the problem and talk
about random forests I'll speak
specifically about implementation that
I've done I'll give some examples and
some anecdotes and discuss ongoing work
then provide a brief summary and talk
about future projects so this this talk
is actually about a project called the
arborist which began as a proprietary
implementation of the random forest
algorithm and the aim at the time was to
provide enhanced performance across a
wide variety of hardware data and
workflows and at the time and we're
talking maybe three years ago now GPU
acceleration was a major concern me the
whole reason the effort started was a
hedge fund manager approached us and
asked us to paralyze the application for
the GPU but the venture under which this
was done has folded so the course was
subsequently open sourced and rewritten
the project name is arborist with an a
the PI package will be called PI burris
and arborist with an R is the our
package the project design goals are a
language agnostic implementation relying
on a compiled core we were looking for
minimal reliance on callbacks and
external libraries and a key goal is to
minimize data movement I claim that's
where you get most of your speed up and
I'll go into what data movement is in
case anyone's not up on that kind of
thing we also strove for ready
extensibility of the code and a common
source base for all subsequent spins so
to to sort of recap what the random
forest algorithm is it's a decision tree
method a binary decision tree method
it's a prediction method that presents a
series of true false questions about the
data and the answer to a given question
determines which of two questions to
pose next and so it's a successive
true/false branching relationship that
justifies that the term tree
no note the different data will take
different paths through the tree where
you end up during your traversal is
referred to as a terminal node or a leaf
and that's how you get the score for the
data that you're trying to evaluate and
you can build a single tree and refine
it with subsequent steps and that's what
boosting is all about but I'm here
talking about rent a forest approaches
in which you grow typically hundreds or
perhaps a thousand trees and the overall
score that you report in the case of
regression is an average and in the case
of classification it's a it's a
plurality now it's actually a
trademarked term but people so I'm very
careful to say random forest algorithm
but I don't think that many people make
the distinction anymore so what it's
trying to do is predict a vector of data
the term of art for that is the response
and if the if the data is is numerical
it's turned regression if it's
categorical it's turned classification
and it trains on a design matrix of
observations on column column wise
they're referred to as predictors and
the predictors can either be numerical
or that can be categorical known as
factors each individual tree is trained
on a randomly selected or bagged set of
matrix matrix rose and that's kind of
what distinguishes a tree at the
beginning of training and predictors are
randomly sampled throughout the training
operation in a way that's separately or
independently done for each know that
you're trying to train validation is
done on the head out subset which is of
course different for each trim and this
enables you to do an independent
prediction on separately provided test
sets excuse me a minute
which we oh thank you i knew i was going
to forget something you picked the right
time okay I wondered what I was going to
screw up and hopefully that's the only
thing so for looking at training as a
process of tree building we begin with a
root node that's conceptually coupled
with the bag data set and a one way to
look at bagging in which I emphasized
during this talk is to think of it as an
indicator set of row indices with
multiplicity so if you're doing sampling
without replacement or I'm sorry with
replacement you're going to sample some
rows many times and some rows 20 times
and that's that's why I'm talking about
an indicator set here and some node
construction or splitting is driven by
information content nodes with
sufficient content will branch into two
new sub nodes and as part of this
process the branch itself is an 80 is
annotated with the splitting criterion
which determines its sense in other
words whether you branch left to right
and again if there's no splitting the
note is terminal it's a leaf and you can
perform this this training operation
however you like you can do depth-first
breadth-first hybrid approach it's
really up to the implementer and their
various reasons for doing these various
ways construction terminates when the
frontier nodes that is the current
collection of leaves simply exhaust
information content but the user can
also specify a termination criterion and
there are several of those in commonly
in use so now to think of building trees
as conditioning which i think is key to
accelerating the algorithm splitting has
the consequence of partitioning the
trade at the training data into
progressively smaller subsets so in a
sense what you do when you when you test
is also what you do when you train your
your your conditioning the data into
smaller and smaller sets the left the
left successor to a node that split
inherits the Sun
space satisfying the criterion and the
right the right successor nodes inherit
the compliments so from this perspective
the the root node trains on all bagged
observations and successor nodes trade
on data that's conditioned by the parent
and as we'll see and I think this is a
an important distinction the condition
subspaces can be characterized as row
sections of the design matrix so in
other words if you look at it that way
the splitting criteria defined
successive by partitions on row indices
and if you look at it from that
perspective you can easily see that the
algorithms got to terminate naturally so
the splitting criteria are formulated as
either order or subset relations with
respect to the predictor on which you're
splitting so for example if its
numerical let's say P if the cut is less
than or equal to 3.2 let's say we branch
left otherwise branch right a typical
style of criterion for a factor
predictor will be a subset membership
relationship again branching left or
right but it a given though the
candidate criteria are obtained over
randomly sampled sets of predictors so
that's going that random sample is going
to differ for every node that you train
but within a predictor the way you you
come up with a criterion a candidate
criterion is to evaluate series of left
and right trial subsets for the
numerical predictors those are simply
distinct cuts in the linear order so if
there are n indices there are n minus 1
cuts four factors what you're doing is
grouping by runs runs of identical value
and trying to partition those into two
subsets so you've got a factorial
relationship going on or an exponential
relationship the overall criterion is
derived from maximizing what's known in
the trade is an impurity in it the idea
is that you're somehow trying to find a
break in the predictor that bests Isis
separates the response into two sets
but when you get into the bowels of this
algorithm you'll note that the trial
scoring is function only a response
evaluate according to predictor order
it's irrespective a predictor but the
node is is scored according to a unique
set of response indices so the only
thing that the predictor is doing is
dictating the order that you're walking
those indices in the values plano rolls
so we're only really ever interested in
predictor ranks and runs at least when
we're training I mean we're we're
scoring it's a little different story so
each trial in particular the winner
determines a by partition of predictor
ranks and because of this pseudo by
jection and the title of this slide you
can see that that induces a by partition
on row indices one set of row indices
characterize the left branch and one set
characterizes the right branch and I
claim that that's the key to
accelerating this algorithm so
throughout training you can look at the
frontier nodes as representing a highly
disconnected partition of the original
bag data as row sections and this is
this some little table sort of gives you
an idea of how bad things can get when
the algorithm is actually training
you're looking across by row so you're
either doing one of regression or a a
classification the the information
criterion is weighted variance in the
case of regression it for numerical
regression of numerical predictors doing
regression there's very little work it's
it's a it's just an index walk
accumulating local Maxima but when you
go to factor prediction first you've got
to accumulate the runs and you've got to
sort them then you've got to walk the
set thankfully in linear order with
classification again the numerical
predictors are fairly cleanly dealt with
but when the one the predictors are our
factor things can get pretty ugly not
only do we have to build a run of the
run sets but we need to walk the power
set of those runs typically if you've
got more than 10 runs you know rather
than do thousands of iterations you just
resort to sampling that's often what's
done there is a shortcut you can take in
the case of binary classification and
just as an aside just as in linear
algebra the appropriate treatment that
in training if you want a fast
implementation depends on your data
think of singular value decomposition
you pay particular attention to the
symmetry properties of your data in
choosing how to how to decompose it
you're not just isn't symmetry
necessarily here but you do have other
things that you're concerned with if you
know you're just doing regression with
numerical predictors you have regular
access patterns and it tends to run
quickly if you've got constraints in the
values you may be interested in using a
smaller data type doing some kind of
numerical simplification if you've got a
lot of ties you may be interested in a
sparse representation so a custom
implementation is going to rely heavily
on the answers to such questions and
therefore if you're trying to do an
implementation that's extensible you
want to make it easy to customize I'll
speak briefly about data locality which
is kind of the central problem we're
trying to solve recall that computer
store data in a hierarchy cpu operates
on registers but once something can't
fit in a register it falls back into a
hierarchy of caches beyond that there's
random access memory and beyond that
there may be hierarchy of disks holding
the data but where you want them is in
the register and getting the data into
the register consumes a lot of clock
cycles the how are the higher up you are
in this in this hierarchy so performance
is best when you're close to register is
and by a similar argument when you're
looping over VES vectors the most
efficient way to do it is when
consecutive iterations are spaced by
predictable amount and relatively short
strides and that's the regular access
pattern that allows a compiler and the
hardware to do a good job and if you are
at all interested in the GPU
implementation you've got this problem
in spades because GPUs tend to
specialize or excel at very highly
regular data access patterns a few
observations about the algorithm you may
have picked up on
the idea that splitting is an
embarrassingly parallel process the
trials can be evaluated on all the nodes
in the frontier independently at the
same time however it's you you do need
some mechanism for keeping track of the
ranks that correspond to the node
indices these vary with the predictor
and I even a solution would be simply
when you're trying to split a node to to
sort the the predictors that's really
slow that's what some of the older
implementations do and they do not scale
well so I mean I think the first thing
people notice when they're trying to
speed up this algorithm is to do a pre
ordering well with pre ordering you can
do an index walk and accumulate per node
state by just looking up what row index
you're currently at and that's the
original approach that the arborist
employed but that has little or no data
locality because the index lookup is
irregular and it requires a large state
budget because you're swapping a lot of
these partial sums in and out every time
you change the node that you're
currently operating on so we came up
with this idea of restaging and that's
simply to maintain a separately sorted
set of state vectors for each predictor
according to node so you begin with this
pre ordered list or set of vectors and
you update it at each level of the tree
via what's known in engineering circles
anyway is a stable by partition that's
the current approach we use data
locality improves with tree depth
because we're moving things over shorter
and shorter distances the further down
the tree we go there's only a modest
amount of state to move if you're using
double precision values with with the
other state it amounts to about 16 bytes
which you're going to get several in a
single cache line if you do it this way
and this has a consequence that
splitting is now quite regular you're
able to pitch that fetch the next datum
or prefetch it for the next iteration of
the loop and a surprise that we noticed
in working on a GPU implementation is
actually the restaging itself can be
done in parallel on simdi hardware the
simdi hardware is what most GPUs are
built with but you're also seeing simdi
engines on
newer Intel chips and arm chips so you
know these things are ubiquitous and the
scheme you use there is known as a
parallel scan which you know if you're
if you're parallel programming you
probably are very familiar with that
excuse me a minute so the code is
organized as as C++ compiled code with
various language front ends are was sort
of the impetus in in the early
development and python is now under
active perhaps active specification is a
more accurate term we're using front end
bridges wherever possible r has a glue
language a template glue language called
our cpp and i intend to use scythe on
for this project and i'll go into some
of the reasons for that again we want to
minimize the use of front-end callbacks
currently what we have to have some
front-end or external library provide
our random number generators a sampling
algorithm and sorting but one nice thing
about the project in the way it's
organized is that the common code base
is used to support to derive all
versions and so far I've been able to to
achieve GPU functionality just by
subtyping the look and feel is is guided
by existing packages we're not really
trying to do anything new or whiz-bang
other than make it go fast many options
are the same but we support only numeric
and factor data if you've got deeper
data type a more sophisticated data type
you've got to derive the factors and
numerical data underlying and the reason
for that is to try to get get away from
Python specific are specific Julia
specific data one distinguishing feature
that we have is we're using Bernoulli
sampling instead of sampling without
replacement to choose among our
predictor sets when we split a node and
an example that's coming up you may I
may illustrate why that's not
necessarily a good idea and I may change
that the implementation is breadth-first
and it allows us to introduce a
specification of the terminate
level we also introduced a information
based stopping criterion called min
ratio and that's about as close as we
get to regularization here I'd like to
do more with regularization I don't know
that this theory is well flushed out
this is what we're offering currently we
do not limit factor cardinality beyond
the size of a bucket that an integer
fits in but if you're a practitioner you
know that's a blessing as well as a
curse and you know anyone is familiar
with these packages know that there's
plenty of stuff we haven't implemented
yet the distinguishing features of the
code is this decoupling of splitting
from road look up it restaging and
highly regular node walk already
mentioned and both stages benefit from
the resulting data locality and
regularity restaging is maintained as a
stable partition and we produce a
lightweight serialized pre tree and
that's allowing us to go from a
multi-node implementation we can ship
data across very cheaply because it's I
claim it's minimal I mean about the only
other thing I can think of to do with it
is to compress it and perhaps that's an
option further down the road we support
a rich intermediate state and in fact
our state is as rich enough that we can
derive quantiles natively you don't have
to call anything else all you have to do
is specify that you want quantile
regression and you've got it it's also
set up to allow workflow internalization
in sort of what the user might call Lu
plus behavior the only example of this
at the moment is nonparametric
resampling but if people can think of
other ideas were more than willing to
entertain them entertain implementing
them so early experience again we began
with in our front end and we compared
performance with the well-known random
forest package in our we worked with
medium data by which I mean things that
could fit in memory and we typically
notice speed ups at about five hundred
to a thousand rows we observed linear
scaling with the number of predictors
and the number of trees as expected and
log linear scaling with the number of
rows and also as expected regression is
much easier to accelerate than
classification
here's just a short example that it's
German credit scoring data it's got 20
predictors it's it's very small a
thousand rows and all I'm trying to
illustrate here are some general speed
ups over the the R implement the random
forest implementation and are as well as
the relative merits of this Bernoulli
sampling versus the without replacement
sampling that random forest uses so the
Bernoulli sampling is in blue and the
the without replacement sampling is in
green and the the y axis is
misprediction rate so I'd say
qualitatively they're about the same but
I'm a little bothered about the behavior
to the right we're doing this Bernoulli
sampling we seem to be consistently
going above what the our implementation
is capable of now this is just one data
set I mean it's got to be explored in
more detail but because of the high
variance of Bernoulli sampling I'm
seriously considering offering this
without replacement scheme at least for
low predictor count and the minimum is
more or less where it should be
somewhere between four or five of
samples per per node is is about where
you'd expect to see the minimum and this
is a ratio of execution times the
arborist is consistently faster but I'll
say that the left really isn't telling
you much on this graph because are the
the arborist isn't really doing much it
at low probability it's at the higher
probability that it's doing more work
and there it's it's getting consistently
faster over the are implement the random
forest implementation and this is
another example that appeared in the
popular press just a few weeks ago there
was a guy doing benchmarking of various
random forest packages and he
specifically excluded the arborist
because he said it was too slow and he
was working on airline flight data and
he was working with a that that data has
eight predictors various row counts up
to 10 million and turn out that slow
down observed had actually been fixed on
the github version he just didn't have
access to it and had no
knowing this but it was a really great
test case and i wish i had more test
cases like that because it caused me to
look much more deeply at some of the
options we were offering and how we were
doing things and that's the reason I
bring it up for one thing because we
were so heavily biased toward doing
things on a GPU we were paralyzing by
predictor and now there's no reason just
to concentrate on predictors you can
paralyze across all pairs all splits and
all predictors at the same time if
you've got the cores we were also not
paying a lot of attention to class
waiting which you really need to do with
unbalanced data that's been dealt with
and we for speed up reasons we
introduced this binary classification
scheme for high cardinality factors and
that's an N log n algorithm but this
points to the need for more and broader
testing and that's one reason I'm here I
mean I really want to see people beat
this thing up and let me just briefly
comment on how we got into the or what
some of the early results we saw with
GPUs so we had a pilot project this is
back when this was still a company with
a group at the University of Washington
and they had some HIV patient data these
were individually sniped in other words
some snips are single nucleotide
polymorphisms there are places in the
genome that humanity differ by there a
good way of trying to figure out whether
you have a predisposition to certain
diseases and they were looking they were
trying to determine whether there were
such d predispositions in HIV patients
in this particular data said had up to a
million predictors although I think in
the lab they actually had a lot more so
what we did is we split off we spun off
bespoke cpu and GPU version specifically
for this data set because that's a
common criticism when you're comparing
GPU and cpu versions you know did you do
all the things you needed to do for that
data well the answer was yes in this
case or we believe it was yes the GPU
version we got to the point we were
training the each treat and almost
entirely on the GPU about all that was
left was a controlling loop
run on the CPU and the following graph
is just illustrates the potential for
this kind of data as the number of
predictors goes up we rapidly approach
the threshold of about a 50-fold speed
up if we're using the GPU training now
there is a bit of a drop off to the
right but I claim that that is a problem
with the data frame feature that we used
in our you know it's it's a linked list
based feature and you we're trying to do
we're trying to copy a read data from it
and it's simply very slow you can always
amortize that by throwing more trees at
the problem but anyway we seem to be
topping out at 50 fold acceleration here
that turned out to be an ad hoc version
it was not scalable as implemented it's
been rewritten since the company folded
but we are now implementing restaging as
a stable partition via parallel scan on
the GPU and I approached some engineers
at Nvidia about whether this was the
right way to to approach restaging they
concurred and they they anticipate good
scaling too much larger data sets but in
general your data sets are not going to
look like this I mean you could have
called that a cherry pick data set other
than the fact that we didn't pick it in
general if you can recall that table I
threw up earlier when you've got mixed
predictor types with multiple
cardinalities you've got huge load
balancing challenges now you do have a
dynamic parallelism option on the GPU
but you still because of this predictor
selection problem you're going to be
sorting data locality every step of the
way it's a really tough problem to do
the general case on the GPU I'm not
saying you can't do it it's a lot of
work and I think the lowest hanging
fruit for the GPU right now maybe these
specialized data sets so however you may
get good speed up by doing just the
regular regression numerical case on the
GPU I haven't tried it yet but you've
still got because because of the row
orderings that you need to have when you
do restaging versus when you split on
the GPU you've got to do something like
a transpose that's slow it's it's doable
but it is one of the problems you're
going to face if you try to do a totally
gpu-based implementation so for now the
emphasis is on splitting on the CPU
because you've got all these cores you
can split over and restage on the GPU as
you can imagine you to do it that way
you're going to be shipping a lot of
data back and forth you're going to
suffer a lot of latency problems well
the solution I'm proposing to this is to
train is to split one tree on the CPU
while you're restaging another tree on
the GPU and cover up the latency via
pipeline and that's what I'm in the
process of working on so a little more
about CPU level parallelism again the
original work focused on predictor level
but we've wider data sets where you had
a lot of predictors and you don't always
have that no no level parallelism has
emerged as an equal player thanks to
this flight delay data but you know the
specter of false sharing looms its ugly
head as you get a hike or count and you
get fairly closely spaced data if you're
not familiar with with false sharing
it's just that multiple threads are
trying to write to the same section of
the of the cash the hardware cannot
arbitrate so it's going to sequential
eyes the data accesses there are ways to
avoid that in the coding you just have
to be mindful of it that's all I'm
saying is you know we've got to pay a
lot more attention to that now
particularly as people start trying this
code out on on amazon web servers so but
the infrastructure is now employees to
support a hierarchical parallelization
model in which a head node actually does
the predictor ordering and then scatters
copy to the to various other nodes that
way multiple nodes can each train blocks
of trees using their own multi-core
hardware and with GP or GPU
participation if there's a GPU around
and then the head node re gathers all
the pre trees breeze that builds the
forest and does the validation getting
this ready for prime time is more a
matter of implement is more matter of
scale
in tuning than anything else so another
another couple words about load
balancing again mixed factor and the
miracle predictors offer the greatest
challenge especially for classification
and in some cases we may benefit from
parallelizing the trial generations
themselves where I'm talking about this
kind of combinatorial blow up that you
see with factor factor based predictors
but irrespective of data type you've got
this inner level pass that's inherently
sequential that you've got to contend
with and again it may make sense to
pipeline to do the inner level pass from
one tree while doing the splitting from
another but again this is just going to
involve a lot more performance testing
to investigate so some additional
projects underway i'm working on a
sparse internal representation it's just
starting out the main challenge is
defining the interface with the host
languages it really has very little to
do with the internal implementation
another problem that I'd like to solve
sooner rather than later or how you deal
with n A's are has several semantic
variations on how to deal with them and
I'm not quainted with how one typically
does this in Python so there's a
learning curve there for me and finally
there's this whole kind of movement
toward post processing of random tree
data that's starting to emerge there's
literature now about feature
contribution analysis and I'm trying to
get these trees fashioned in a cent in a
form that makes it easier for developers
of other packages to go and offer these
graphical tools to explore feature
contributions so I'll talk briefly about
the goals of the pie breast and that's
to encourage flexing and testing by the
broader machine learning community I
mean machine letting people seem to one
who's Python so so let's go there but
will honor the precedent of psychic
learn in terms of features and style but
I want to provide are like abstractions
such as data frames and factors i mean i
think you know if you want to get work
done you need something like that but at
the same time want to minimize the
impact of the host language on unit user
data would be really nice if a person
can take the same data with men
no processing or post-processing perhaps
and move it between our and pied and
Python as needed and that's really going
to stress the software organization and
the design so the decisions i've made so
far are to implement the bridge in
scythe on because of its emphasis on
compilation panda support will be there
because panda supports data frame and
categories and so far from what i've
seen i'm really impressed with the way
pandas does categories I believe it's
better than ours you know and I'm an
hour person and using numpy for random
number generation sorting and sampling
callbacks and I've considered some other
options like swag cff I&C types but I'm
becoming sold on sythe on but if people
have opinions you know you can it cost
me in the hall and tell me what your
opinion is opinions are so in summary
you know we've only adhered to a few
rigid design principles and that's
constraining data movement and
maintaining a language agnostic compiled
core implementation we've stuck with a
common source base we still do there's
plenty of room for improvement I don't
claim to have all the answers maybe just
a few but right now the emphasis is on
load balancing because I believe that's
that's the lowest hanging fruit both for
the CPU and the GPU longer term actually
medium-term solicit help and comments
from the community both Python are and
perhaps Julia we'll see I'd like to
offer expanded use of templating because
it's going to allow users to build their
own implementations with the types they
need for the job everybody always wants
out of memory support so that's a
direction to head in and this may be a
pipe dream but perhaps one day it will
be possible to sniff the data matrix and
see which of many implementations you
might want to run on your on your data
set and something that's very easily
done will be to provide plugins for
other splitting methods so I'm not just
genie and weighted variants that's just
a matter of putting them in the code I
mean there's not much to that and I'd
like to internalize additional workflows
so thanks very much to Steve elston of
quanta analytics for suggesting that
German credit scoring data thanks to a
beef laxman whom i'm working with on
sparse data representations and and the
PI implementation and a special thank
you to seattle puppy which has been a
great organ for organizing and sort of
getting the word out about python use in
the community at all levels whether it's
just helping people out or doing
something really analytic space like
this and I think we're 35 minutes so I
think there's time for questions and
that's how to get me sir taking forever
to run with this algorithm like I'll go
to that and try variable and I'll say
okay let's limit the number of variables
I'm trying at each partition I was just
wondering like have you seen anything
interesting liquid when you go to
parallel eyes that you know
oh it's a pain for the GPU because it
gives you data locality issues I mean
unless you you just want to always
operate on all predictors and just throw
away the ones you don't use but you know
on okay the yeah yeah on the GPU you're
talking about what they call local
memory and you've got to pull in as much
data to fill local memory as possible
otherwise you're wasting resources and
if you're only looking at a few
predictors at a time in their sparsely
spaced you're just going to be pulling
in things you don't need I think the
correct way to do this on the GPU is to
have a secondary staging pass which is
knowledgeable about the next level in
the tree impacts the dating of data
accordingly I mean that's all I've been
able to come up with so far but I'm not
being paid to do this research so I mean
it's kind of my spare time sure
oh right now I'm just working with some
development development machines that I
have locally and we're talking four
cores one GPU of a fairly recent vintage
and then once I'm satisfied with that I
can jump up and start using Amazon nodes
that have one or two GPUs attached but
I'm limited by the budget available to
for this machinery and the amount of
interest in the community so the more
interest there is the bigger the systems
that this will be tested on but I'm
starting small sir
oh yeah yeah that that's wide open and
we're seeing more and more implement
earn your talk about the on-die GPUs
yeah i think there's plenty of potential
for those things I just haven't gotten
there
yeah oh just one at the moment yeah what
internalizing workflows yeah okay yeah I
probably misspoke if I said that what I
meant was I'm looking for other work
flows to internalize I view the you know
the whole bootstrapping resampling thing
is a done deal I mean all I'm doing is
is permuting the why the response the
training response and letting the user
determine what they want to do next but
what I'm referring to when I say other
workflows is think of how you would
invoke random forests day after day or
you know in a script and just like if
you're familiar with the carrot package
in our it enables you at a slightly
higher level 22 you know very Karama
ters if you will and i'm thinking of
internalizing more of those kinds of
things that way you don't have to do
only the sort things once and if you're
in a multiple node framework that that's
a big deal so that's what I was
referring to but yeah I was not talking
about other ways of resampling
how
no no that's what I meant what I said
this is under active specification so
but it'll be there all right thank you